[Music]
welcome mol thank you for joining us
today
I like this environment a little more
intimate and feels very googley in a
sense so my name is JD I'm a product
manager with stackdriver
and I'm here today with sha Shan Shan
who's going to join us later he's a
technical lead for our kubernetes
monitoring experience and we're gonna
tell you a little bit today about how do
we do a kubernetes monitoring a little
bit in the way that Google does some of
you let me just check here who was
yesterday in the talk the hybrid
monitoring and logging session a few
people okay so you'll see it very much
the same demo in a sense and a few more
other things that we're going to show
you as well so let us get started
that oh yeah that introduction was I
said we're going to try to go through a
couple of scenarios how we monitor and
troubleshoot kubernetes in production
we'll talk about some of the best
practices that we do and a little bit
about observability and and so forth we
do assume some basic knowledge and
kubernetes of course as we're doing some
things here in that end so first thing
is let's talk about observability
reliability and software velocity just a
quick show of hands who here's developer
all right almost everybody anybody in
operations here as well and who does
look truly devops okay sir great so
let's say thinking from all of you
developers and many of you who may be
our partners our customers and so on you
know that software velocity now becomes
a real necessity it's a it's a
competitive advantage for you to be able
to innovate in your market to compete
for business compete for some customers
and so on you really want to be able to
accelerate the pace of your software
velocity of the innovation and so on now
the difficult thing however is to do
that while at the same time maintaining
reliability right you're able to do one
or the other very well
now one of the key things that Google
has done that is very good at is for the
almost two decades now we've been able
to have
a great pace of innovation while still
maintaining software reliability and
also minimizing security exposure so
there's something that Google has done
at massive scale of being able to do
both of these things and so what we're
trying to do now on our team and on the
sre group and so on is to externalize
many of these sre practices so that our
customers and our developers and so on
can do the same things in a way that
Google does
now when I say monitoring or developing
and the way that Google does sometimes I
get you know high eyebrows say well we
we don't have the scale that Google does
we don't need to do exactly the same
thing now our point is that yes
regardless of scale you do want to take
advantage of some of these best
practices because you do face the same
type of issues the way you want to
deploy applications that when you want
to monitor at them and so on are the
same type of problems just the scale
might be different so let's talk a
little bit about that in general so
kubernetes is an example of how we've
been doing this right the the way that
Google does things today everything very
much runs in a container like all we
have an internal system we call board
where everything is isolated very much
in a container say so as you see here
we're really worried on average on a
week we launched more than four billion
containers so we've certainly amassed
some experience and how to deploy and
then manage this type of container based
applications and so when we're trying to
do now with our processes and our tools
is to external externalize those best
practices precisely and we've been doing
this in multiple ways the first one is
our infrastructure so internally aside
from our of course our infrastructure we
call Google 3 it's it's done in a way
where developers from the very beginning
you they can really focus on writing
code a lot of the instrumentation is you
know ready happens sort of automatically
we know the type of things that that
infrastructure is expecting so we can do
some things automatically right now of
course we cannot just put Google 3 out
but we've done some of these things via
some of the externalization like
kubernetes precisely right kubernetes is
in some ways that externalization of our
Borg infrastructure and practices now
you saw yes
the keynote our our Google cloud service
platform announcement with a steno and
so on so we've done the similar thing to
manage services across in coordination
so east you as an example for
instrumentation we use something called
sensors and Google has invested now and
externalizing that via open sensors so
the intent here is to give you a way
inch in which you can instrument your
application one way or one time and then
you can choose multiple backends and
switch over you may want to use Google's
start driver as a back-end you may want
to use a different back-end to do your
monitoring and your operations and
that's fine because you don't need to go
back and change your instrumentation and
that's the way we do it internally and
that's what we're doing now outside and
the same thing for in terms of our
procedure calls we now have G RPC as an
externalization so that's a
infrastructure and people in some sense
right the the processes that we do now
best practices we you know I'm using a
collective we I had nothing to do with
that book but we at Google a sorry
well we've wrote that the book and
operations literally site reliability
engineering and who here has visited the
59 on Moscone West if you haven't first
just a couple of hands stop by it's it's
a booth with all of our s re a team and
you get ideas you can actually get a
free copy of the book and signed up and
everything else ups I invite you to do
that
so we've amassed all these practices
we're now externalizing them in terms of
books white papers training and
certification and so on I looked at
LinkedIn just very recently on my
profile at least I saw roughly about
26,000 people with roles now that have s
re in the title so we're certainly now
making a mess in terms of changing a
little bit of the culture and what
involves in these type of practices and
then finally our tools of course if we
don't have the right tools that are
trying to implement the same type of
workflows that comes from both best
practices and those processes then you
you you have a mismatch and so now stat
driver is an example of that tool it
started initially as an acquisition we
did four and a half years ago or so but
that was just the beginning that was
focusing on just a small piece of it
which was monitoring and we've expanded
that into a full product suite that now
has multiple components so let me tell
you a little bit about start
now it's a fully managed product we have
on cloud and the main mission that we
have on our team is to help developers
tune operators keep your applications
running fast and always available and a
key thing here with stack drive is that
was built from the ground up to help you
do your apps and monitor your apps no
matter where they run they may be
running on Google cloud they may be
running on AWS they may be running on
cloud native infrastructure as we'll
show today with kubernetes and now with
the kubernetes monitoring then we also
have the possibility to monitor on Prem
as well now all of this is built on a
massive platform that we have at Google
in our backends in our store since the
one and the key thing here is that we
will be doing is we're amassing as a lot
of signals throughout the full stack
starting from our cloud services
you know from Google cloud from AWS to
operating system and third-party
application components let's say in your
in your app you're using let's say nginx
Redis Kafka anything that lets out
there's a third-party application
components all the way to your your main
application your business you know what
it's meant to do so all those signals we
get all of those together it's not just
about monitoring is not just about
metrics it's actually logs metrics
events snapshots from debugs
traces and we get all those signals
together into our back ends our back
ends are stores and we have look this is
the this part that I mentioned is a
massive platform to give you an idea we
monitor in in this time series database
that we have internally we monitor more
than 3 billion resources roughly about
480 terabytes in RAM because it's a
highly distributed in memory time series
database on our logging back-end we have
in a day roughly 35 petabytes of day so
it's a massive infrastructure that we
have they're not putting outside for all
of you to use and take advantage of that
stack driver is built on top of that
infrastructure and so what we do is we
use that and then we create a set of
tools that we have exposed to all of our
customers so you can do visualizations
use them in dashboards create multi
conditioning alerts have notification
channels to many
from ways and to do that we actually
rely on many of our partners so what
we're doing is we actually are building
all this because we know we cannot be
everything to everybody right there's
things that we cannot do is not a core
focus and so many of our partners come
in and and fill that gap most
importantly many of those partners come
in and feel you know couldn't help us
build that ecosystem and created much
better build value on top of this
platform so we have a few of our
partners here today many of you you'll
see here now I'm actually excited to
talk specifically about one partner X
matters we just announced a partnership
with them and they're helping us build a
set of notification channels and
integrations so that I helps customers
when you're they're using stat driver if
you get a notification when there's a
particular incident there was a failure
now using X matters our customers will
have ability to then integrate with many
other services including dozens and
hundreds of integrations in that sense
so it really helps customers get to the
core of an issue and resolve things
faster and so forth so let's go now
briefly into our monitoring offering
today the kubernetes monitoring solution
and you know the building modern abs
it's a quite different from what it used
to be in the past today many of you
raised your hand saying you're a
developer and you know that is I wish
most of you want to just focus on
building code am i right yes if you
could we can't anymore right like
there's so many things that we have to
do we want to choose our infrastructure
we want to do setups then we're going to
do a containerization work with a
specific orchestration system most
likely kubernetes choose storage
instrumental applications to do then
monitoring set up our monitoring and
observability tools and so on
so getting observability and by the way
I'm using the term observability here
and I know he sort of became kind of
like a buzz word recently but at Google
we truly mean and from many years ago
we've been talking about observability
it's not just monitoring monitoring is
one piece of things monitors just add
activity of going in and looking at a
specific things to prevent failures
observability is more a property of a
system so from the beginning what we're
trying to do
is to get our systems being designed
with reliability in mind it really is an
engineering practice and so we're trying
to increase the signals that's why you
see metrics logs traces all together
because we're trying to increase the
observability of our systems so we can
know how they operate in under normal
circumstances and also how they operate
when there's failure so that when we can
quickly resolve issues speed root cause
analysis and help us resolve Asia and
then learn back on kubernetes actually
makes things a little bit trickier
because on the one hand it gives us so
much flexibility is great we start with
new micro services so it really allows
us to break this monolith into multiple
micro service but that means that we
have more pieces to monitor and operate
the second thing is that we of course
have abstracted infrastructure you have
so much flexibility you can use
different types of controllers and
deployments and staple sets and all
these different components and then
again when you're using those now you
have to infer the state of those
components when something goes wrong so
you really want to be able to have a
pretty well spread out of server ability
throughout your entire kubernetes
environment and finally kubernetes is
really a highly dynamic environment if
you're using auto scaling and and of
course the scheduling and restarting and
so on that's a natural occurrence and
kubernetes so you want to be able to
have a system that allows you to always
know the state of where things are no
matter where where they are and of
course if you're not really looking at
your applications necessarily like
knowing work and which machines they are
right that's the idea we want you to not
think about any of those things and so
but that means now that you need to keep
track of where your application is and
what is doing and so on so what we have
right now is a new solution which is
star driver kubernetes monitoring and we
announced recently it's in beta and
we've been expanding it rapidly so we
invite you all of you to please start
using it if you haven't already gave us
feedback the feedback view gives right
now like we directly are reading those
those messages so we want to build a
product that is most useful to you
there's many things that are not
available yet inside private kubernetes
monitoring we want to get those things
out to you as fast as
so let me go through it very rapidly
some of the things that we have first
it's comprehensive observability what do
I mean by that out of a box without you
having to do anything you get all this
instrumentation done for you know
for free so to speak you get
instrumentation or all your kubernetes
objects and you get not just metrics you
get metrics logs and we have traces as
well and there's events and metadata and
so on so really trying to increase that
it works very well with open source from
the ground up we built it and integrated
with primitives which is of course the
the most well known monitoring open
source solution for kubernetes it's
multi cluster monitoring which is a
difference that you see for many other
products outside in a single place we're
giving you a way to do multiple
management of multiple clusters and it
doesn't matter where it runs we can
monitor your cluster on Prem or your
cluster on kubernetes engine or your
cluster running on on AWS ec2 instances
for instance one last thing that I would
say in this respect is the fact that it
you have the observer ability no matter
what your role is so goes back to that
idea of this platform that we created
this platform for us create a a single
source of truth many of you are using
multiple tools very lightly and what we
what we do is we have just that single
platform where all these signals come
together so you don't have to stitch and
cobble together multiple tools to try to
create that source of truth so if you're
a DevOps or an SRE
you may want to look primarily at your
infrastructure if you're a developer you
may look at your application and your
workloads and so on which will show in
the demo and your if you're a security
engineer you may actually be looking at
your logs and audit logs and audit trail
and and so on there's actually also part
of stack driver so I mentioned before it
works very well with open source with
prometheus one of the main maintainer of
Prometheus fabián trainers join Google
our team just a couple of months ago so
we're directly working with him to make
sure that we continue to contribute to
prometheus to expand and contribute to
this vibrant community and ultimately to
make it very easy to switch and make
sure that Prometheans integrations can
move into cloud when when it's
appropriate and when wanted I need it
so this is what will we've seen today
a hybrid multi cluster approach for
kubernetes monitoring and I think the
best way to do that is is through our
demo but one last thing I'll say is that
this offering works very well it's near
self-contained like you get your
kubernetes observability but it works
even better when you use it with the
rest of the stack driver tools and
hopefully at the end we'll show you a
little bit of this the idea again by
using all this steel those tools and
signals together is that we try to give
you a means to speed your root cause
analysis you'll see in a couple of the
demos here that we're trying to focus
your attention into the information that
matters the most to you so that you
follow the trail that we believe is that
is the one most likely to give you the
root cause for things so with that I
will turn to a short song who is going
to tell us a little bit about the
internal architecture okay thanks JD so
this is so song I'm the tech lead of a
spectral kubernetes monitoring we switch
back to slides for one second and switch
back to slides please
I'll quiz to reach back to slides for
once again
yeah so
so I'm going to give you a very brief
overview about what our stackdriver
accompanies monitoring architecture it
is so as you can see so there's a cupola
cubelet running in your cluster so there
we have some of the kubernetes metrics
very important one like the CPU usage
restock hand and whatever is there are
collecting by the hip-stir
and we we offer a structure we have
monitoring API which is public on the
internet so hipster sending this metric
into our monitoring API that is how we
collect system battery for your
equivalents application in the same time
we have the structure of a promiscuous
collector which is a sidecar running in
your pot and it collects scraped all the
Prometheus metrics that's all a weight
about there for your config and also
right into our monitoring API so this is
the past for the how matrix flow into
stack driver in the same time we have
the two teaming set one stack driver
metadata agent because as all the
matters are like you kubernetes label
your hierarchy in your kubernetes and
what all the configure has specify and
then sending it to the resource metadata
API and logging agent is also another
team and set it collects all your
standard a standard error or your other
logs you care about and then sending
into our logging API which is packaged
our log in storage this is the
architecture of this offering so we want
to explore a little bit more about how
Prometheus metrics integrase happens so
as you can see here so that on the top
is a great great chart is the like how
you do Prometheus metrics in open source
so there's a official promise a
collector scraping as Prometheus pots
and then sending the data in graphing in
crow fauna on spectra where we have
another way or another
Prometheus collector which collects data
and ascending is to structure away back
home which is cloud monarch which is our
Google
a or time series database with JD has
mentioned before it supports all of our
Google were closed including all of the
Google cloud platform Matt is a time
series database for that and we have the
structure monitoring UI
which is graph the time series data from
monarch you can also use our graphing
our integration used to use profanity
from the monarch to graph whatever -
what you want so this is the brief
introduction about our architecture now
let's go through the demo time
one more slice our explain so this is a
very classical demo that probably some
of you have already see is a PAC clinic
from spring communication and so how
many of you have have passed like if
raise the hand oh come on you have okay
we have a plenty of people I have passed
so as you can see today we are going to
use this technique demo - this is going
to give you this of owners and in some
of the paths with it Pat information and
some the doctor for your path so let me
very briefly describe how this
application is set up so as you can see
we say this is a today's demo is a
hybrid mo so that's why we set up a GK
cluster and the UM brain cancer they are
both running the same app as you can see
there's a API gateway which is routing
your all your traffic into different
backends there's a customer service we
should give you the detail of owners and
the wizzy service which tell you how
what's your visit to the pack linic and
some doctor service of these connecting
to a remote cloud spanner storage with
all of your data so this is the setup ok
so I'm heading back to JD and but we we
will run a demo for this product.if
monitoring we switch to demo
Thank You Shawn all right so let's say
let's try to show you a little bit of
this application so we get a sense for
it and orient ourselves so a short song
we're saying it's just an app very
simple one allows you to get information
for as an owner of a veterinary clinic
I just track who are my customers what
pets they have what visits they've done
to the veterinary clinic and so on so
let's show the list of owners shows from
right now get a sense for for those the
app you may see it it's a little bit
flaky on purpose to try to show some
issues with latency and other things so
what we're gonna do here is add a new
pet to a pet owner and we can do I guess
the same one at the date of birth and
then the type maybe you want to
introduce a bugger with a the cat just
in case we want to use it later if we do
add another pet and that's a very
apropos name so we introduce a little
thing here so we get a error requests
and so forth just in case they may be
useful for us to demonstrate other
things later on if we have time all
right and now we could do other things
we can do
add visits for the pets if we want to
have a more data and traffic into this
application but what we want to do now
is to actually create some actual
traffic for it we would be asking you as
we did in the demo yesterday were asking
you to do do this in particular but
let's do it now today we have one
command what show song is doing right
now is we're going to our on-prem
cluster and now we're adding a we're
actually scaling that cluster to make
sure it simulates some traffic let's do
the same now on the gke side we run the
same exact command we're just going to
scale up this Arlo generator and then
essentially creating that particular
traffic here for kubernetes now sure
Shawn mentioned you have many ways of
doing monitoring you could have done
Prometheus and Griffin are most likely
for using open-source what we're going
to do today is just focus on the
kubernetes monitoring experience so
we're gonna do just that
why don't we try to go now into
kubernetes monitoring
which we do by going into our cloud
console you choose the monitoring piece
from the stack driver section that gets
you into the stack driver console this
is the stack driver monitoring piece
remember stack driver is actually a full
suite with many components right now six
different components so we're in the in
the monitoring console now and by going
through resources and kubernetes we'll
get to the kubernetes monitoring offer
and so you see here the essentially that
kubernetes monitoring console right now
and just let me try to orient ourselves
here a little bit on this console on the
upper side you see that widget is the
event timeline it's our event widget
what we're trying to do here is surface
kubernetes events that may be relevant
to you and this is actually a heat map
so you see the more transparent colors
you know the more solid colors actually
have higher frequency of events the less
solid ones are you know less events and
so on now you can modify time set and
and and other things but the important
thing here is that we want to surface
events that you can then correlate with
the state of your kubernetes environment
today in Veda
we're just surfacing events related to
incidents now incidents are essentially
violations of your alerting policies so
you created alerting policies by
defining you know let's say conditions
that you believe are the your own notion
of health right something you would say
this is when this happens most likely a
failure or an yeah a situation we want
to avoid perhaps is likely to occur so
we want to use those when a failure
occurs we create an incident and those
are the ones you're seeing here now
let's focus our attention on the pane
below this is our multi cluster
monitoring and as you can see here
there's already two clusters the ones we
have out of the box you actually get
those clusters together in a single
place now for the GK a cluster there's
nothing you need to do right no watchman
is needed you get pre integration with
kubernetes engine all the data gets in
and and there's nothing to do for the
on-prem cluster the only thing you need
to do is deploy a stack driver agents so
the agents that shrunk showed us earlier
a metadata age and
the logging agent and so on we deploy
those with a very simple set of
instructions now in this pane down below
we also try to surface information that
is key to give you a sense of the health
of your cluster so we have pot readiness
we have incidents that may have occurred
in any of the objects and we have some
key consumption utilization for
resources and so on like CPU and memory
relative to requests and limits you may
have created on these objects alright
the other thing that I want to show you
is the fact that I mentioned this before
in one of the slides
no matter the role you have you can
choose a different view on this part so
if you're an operator or SRE then you
may want to actually look in your
infrastructure and take a look at your
notes and the health of your nodes and
and how performant they are and so on so
we can do that if you're a developer
then you may actually want to look at
your deployments or your services of
your application right and so short song
showed us a few more earlier and there
we go we have a one of our the default
namespace that he's going in and notice
right away that there's something here
and this is what I meant earlier now
because we scaled up and show song is
gonna show us that in a minute
something is going on you immediately
see that there's something we're
focusing your attention on the pieces of
kubernetes that you may want to look at
right now and chiron will demonstrate
that in in a little bit more detail in a
minute
so you can go now into the details of
many of these kubernetes objects simply
by inspecting them on demand so here we
just clicked on a pod and you can see
that it's still ready it's running it
actually has an incident open that pod
specifically so you know there's
something particularly on that pod and
that I can go in in detail through the
rest of the key metrics memory storage
networking and so forth and in the same
place we also includes logs and metadata
for you right so now it's it's really
logs that are only relevant for that
pause for that particular period of time
events and metadata that are only
relevant for that particular period of
time in those components and that's what
I meant earlier but trying to increase
the observability of your kubernetes
environments not just having you to look
for those things in separate tools
altogether with rather bringing all
those signals in the same place at the
right time with the right context now
one last thing that they wanted to show
you was that you can use all the other
features that you have in stackdriver
but particularly when you're trying to
resolve incidents very like that you
want to explore things on demand we
mentioned before we have an integration
with prometheus so all this Prometheus
metrics have been already ingested into
stackdriver so we're gonna take a look
at those with the metrics Explorer and
with metric explorers you have access to
all of the objects components on
kubernetes all the metrics that are
available and Australia is showing us
right now we have all the Prometheus
metrics ingested already so take a look
at one of the JVM metrics that we have
seen this is a java application so we
have one of them we can do the memory
use bytes have some interesting signals
on that we can we can show so we've got
auto-completion gets you to the metrics
that you need very fast and then use
bytes okay so we have a lot of signals
in that sense it may be hard to to
figure out exactly what's going on but
what we can do is we added a lot of
dimensions to this kubernetes objects
right and so now you have labels and
metadata that are coming from your
environment or even from user-defined
labels that you can use to filter and
aggregate and group by to get you right
very fast to where you need and so let's
filter now for a service name as you're
doing and we knew before there was
something with APA gave way above so
let's filter by that one and then you
can further group by something else or
aggregate to not just have a sum but
rather perhaps a mean or naughty 9th
percentile or something of the sort oh
and then the last thing that you can do
is you also do outlier mode so we still
have a lot of signals here so you can
look at the top and objects and so we're
now looking at the top three top five
containers by JVM memory use bytes all
right so that gives you just a whirlwind
tour of the main things that you can do
on the monitoring piece with the
integration of metrics logs and so forth
so I'm going to show you a switch with a
short song so we can look at more of the
troubleshooting scenario that started to
occur right now
okay so I'm going to give a demo about
the troubleshooting scenario so in as a
software engineer or operation engineer
one of the very common error case will
happen and we will deal with in daily
work is when your applications receiving
a large volume of traffic your
application may become less responsive
or slow and so this is what we have
simulated a moment ago if you recall
while JD's speaking we generate traffic
to both kubernetes engine cluster and
open cluster and while you were watching
the previous demo I'm hey I as the uncle
engineer has been paged by by the by an
incident so let's go to my gmail
accounts and I see there already a true
incident report has been sent against to
me
for example like this this is this
incident has tell me there are too many
500 has been returned from my services
and on the bottom of this incident
report there's a view incident link
which will directly to redirect me to
the stackdriver incident overview page
so as you can see here so my service is
apparently returning a lot of 500
response and this is concerning because
this is how my customer are experiencing
and this is a too many 500 then more
than my soo allows so I want to identify
I want to resolve this issue as soon as
possible let's move to the custom - flow
I have three previously build for my
hybrid environments so this is a custom
dashboard I built before that who draw
several charts about the very useful
metrics from to help me observe my
hybrid environments let's quickly go
through them so on the first row there
are two charts of about my HTTP request
rate and error error rate this is to
slice by the cluster and on a second row
there are two JVM metrics because my PAC
clinic app is a java application so JVM
metrics are important for me and this is
corrected by Prometheus and install
in stackdriver i also have the cpu limit
utilization and memory limit utilization
and restock hands some are classical
system metrics I will take a look and so
ok so this is a glance view of this
dashboard let's see how we can use it so
from the first chart we already see
there's a reasonably man above 300
requests per second goes to post my own
prayer and caster and kuba nice engine
cluster this is working as intended
because this is one my load balancer
come fix and but if we look at the
second chart which is my error rate I
can see that's about all of the 500 rays
are coming from my um friend classroom
so it's a parody of very strong signal
to tell me there's something wrong in my
own brain caster as a natural reaction I
may want to type in with my own brain
cluster and figure out what's wrong
there but our si best practice tell us
we should contain and my together issue
the first so the ideal solution here is
we drain the omron cursor and failover
it's trophy to somewhere else
the first choice is our covenants engine
castle so I want to but before I do that
I want to be ensured additional safety I
want to make sure my coupon is engine
cluster can sustain the load if I double
the size so let's go to the kubernetes
monitoring UI and take a look at the
infrastructure view if we expand the
kubernetes engine cluster we will see
there are six nodes there some of the
nodes are reasonably busy but most of
them are empty so it gives me a
confidence I can fail over the traffic
into this coupon is changing faster and
is more than enough to sustain the law
so that let's go ahead and do it so from
this terminal JD what rady is doing is
to Skelton manually drained on foreign
cluster by scaling the traffic on and in
the same time we will go to a crucial
for kubernetes engine
and that's a 6k up the traffic so this
is how we do the manual affair over from
one cluster to another cluster and then
after it's after the command finish
let's go to go back to our cousin
dashboard to see how the traffic goes
yeah as you can see here from the chart
our important caster traffic has been
dropping and our 500 is also dropping in
a moment later and I mean about 2
minutes later we will see the company's
engine class or traffic going up so
because we already see the 500 is
dropping this give us a reasonable
confidence this is me issue has been
contained since every minute counts in
my firefighting scenario so that's just
jump directly into identifying the Luke
horse and then we will go back and then
see whether my app has been back into
normal state in two minutes let's go to
a company's monitoring UI
and go to service tab because this is
what where the service is returning 500
and open the on prank asta as you can
see there the incident can't : give you
a very clear signal where you should
focus your attention to this is like we
need to go through and comprehend before
namespaces and apparently API gateway is
the problematic one let's expand it and
inspect the pause inside of it so let's
click on pause we see there's a
contender returning to many 500 and from
first chart is a container restart it
doesn't have any restarts it's a good
signal it means my container is running
healthy and we see the memory usage is
reasonably high but not out of whack and
we also see the CPU mem CPU usage it's
it's also like about 80% use it's
because we are receiving a lot of
traffic it is reasonable storage is flat
and network usage is high because we're
receiving high amount of the traffic so
after looking all these system matches
it doesn't seem to tell me my cabinet
infrastructure is having any issue it
seems like then what could be the issue
at this moment is the log will help us a
lot as you can see here there's a lock
race has been draw here and you can see
there's an unreasonable amount of error
logs has been written and about 40% of
you error log error
of your locks and arrows and if we go
down to the lock snippy ears we can
apparent see there something has been
throwing here is probably go away
because we have trained a cluster let's
go to dogs viewer click go to login link
on the bottom and it will redirect me to
blocks viewer with more focused view or
to get more details this will keep
filter down directly into the spots will
keep all I was looking at and a
restricted to the time frame well why my
instant happens this matters the most
for me as you can see here from the
locks viewer we already see a dozens of
like occurrence of the exception had
been thrown from my code as you can see
there's a runtime exception with the
error message unable to find unable to
fetch details for owner one and this is
tell me something wrong in my code and
this is a stack trace so I can scroll
down and further and then see where this
problematic lines has been thrown as you
can see here this is the API control API
gateway controller line 454 it's the one
where the error has been thrown now it
gives me a very good confidence that
this is the probabilities can give me
help me understand something
let's go to a cold
okay apparently it's not in this file
let me do it yeah yeah we should do we
should show the debugger as well yeah
sure okay okay so this is the file where
the API gateway is there and then we
remember the error message we says
unable to fetch details for owner one so
there's a parent III very problematic
line there somebody from my team has
inside this line to throw five hundred
after tossing a coin this is like why my
own prone caster is returning 500 for
portion of my trophy so I have already
identified a root cause the next step
for me is to fix the back we deploy the
app to make Imran castle and Andrea my
castle
then you will bring all my hybrid
environment back to normal so as you can
see from this demo structural kuba is
monitoring integrates both or all the
metrics logs metadata and events that
can give you the observability you need
to monitor and troubleshoot your hybrid
environments we also want to give you a
one more demo about one other very
important very fancy thing here so as
you see that the scenario as Joe is a
very simple troubleshooting because I
looking at in a three lines of code and
know what happens but in a more
complicated situation it's very hard
even you have the error message and
stack trace you won't be able to easily
identify whether easier it is may be
because you are in a very big thing or
what maybe because you are developing a
very complicated app you don't know
every line of the code so if it's as a
software developer I really wish I can
do the debugger debugging in the real
world productions traffic but we know is
a most close to impossible because in a
local instance you can be back with your
ID
you can stop you can hang on your
application you can step through order
code and see what environment worry
about video or other ways it's a more
old-school style is that you put the
lock lines and then you rebuild your app
you Randy and you'll see your blog where
how what's happening in your application
but we can we can not do the second way
in production as well because you don't
want to be during your firefighting you
add some dark lines deploy your app to
production and then up waiting for the
production traffic IDI it will take
hours and it's deploying a problematic
app during outages make you even more
with riskier this is like almost
impossible but stuck to a debugger make
it happen for you so let's go to
structure a debugger so as you can see
here so because we I deploy my code in
key hub let's switch to my github repo
with my code and if we scroll down you
will see my problem at the same code
there within debugger what the thing I
can do is I can insert a lock point and
a snapshot or my code and it doesn't
affect any of your production traffic at
all but in the meantime it just assumed
this line is already in your code and
export a lock point or capture the
snapshot and then writing both to your
lock as to sector logging and then you
can see what is happening what's the
environment for it keeps your very close
to real debugging on your real real
world traffic let's give a demo here so
for example in this line 54 that's the
problematic line let's add a lock point
say ok say a lost coin coin toss so
that's why I'm about to throw a 500 and
then I log E as an arrow lot because
it's easier for me to field in future
and that's save it also before I do the
final return and let's add a line in
line 16 that's at a snapshot that can
give you a sense what before I returning
this call what
my service environment looks like okay
so we have already set up we are waiting
for traffic to hit because we already
trained on Frank Astra now we have to
manually generate some traffic here so
that just go to the owner details page
we need to go to on a details page and
then let's pick whatever one and this is
the 500 let's customer experience e
let's refresh refresh refresh keep
refreshing because it's a tossing a coin
so sometimes we will get like a printing
it's a little bit unlucky you see a lot
of 500 here so let's choose another one
yeah okay we see the success case let's
go back to debugging as you can see here
so this is a code trace there so success
case has been caught by my debugger
let's open the owners variable this is
the owner details as a father second
sets a sex case where you can see this
is the name of the owner which we see
successfully being returned and all the
environment where both this nice Java
file contains okay we can also take a
look at a lot point so for example this
is like the dog has been written into
your spectral block storage this is
where you can come combined with all
i'll other your information block you
can understand what's the flaw what's
happening it gives you close to your
real war debugging scenario and so this
is the debugging another tool we can
show here is also very useful is trace
using trace it can give you a way to do
the latency analysis like for example
the load we have generating we've all
been captured by structural tracing this
is a distributed tracing system and we
can see how it goes through how the
traffic flows amount multiple backhands
in my services let's pick a success case
here as you can see this is a hitting my
um friend Custer and at first it goes to
the customer service that we can open
the box
to see what law has been written by each
of the services this dialogue has been
written in the same time and first go to
customer service and then go to a weekly
service at the bottom as you can see
here so this is the collecting order
trades from all your distributed sister
be score we call it a PC call as well
and we can also take a look at the 500
in Aereo if we switch here and filter by
500 there are some the arrow locks we
just hit remem so from here you can see
if we open the show locks this is where
it before hits any backhands it just
throw a 500 and then this is the error
message and runtime exception has been
captured okay so we switch back to
slides for one minute so this is the end
of this demo we are going to write song
showed the idea here again is you have
many tools available from monitoring to
logging to debugger we didn't show you
error reporting today but there's a few
errors that you would see and we
categorized those errors directly for
you so it's easy to do exception
analysis as well and when you use all
those tools together you get very rich
comprehensive observer ability of your
kubernetes environment now you can help
with multiple things of course you can
increase that observer ability for
making sure that you get out-of-the-box
metrics that your kubernetes environment
gives you and and so that we do that for
you we take that toil away from you to
make it easy very much in the way that
Google does internally and you certainly
can supplement with third-party
application metrics and your business
that find metrics for which you can use
Prometheus or anything else that you may
want for instrumentation hopefully using
open sensor so you can do it just once
and then choose any other back-end that
you may be interested in make sure that
these tools pay attention to resource
requests and limits and so on some of it
the tools we have on some places will
show you like no data available or node
requester or resource request or limit
set it is it is important that's a good
best practice that you use that and set
your resource request some limits in
your kubernetes environment and also you
want to make sure that your information
is available in a consistent weight to
so take advantage of the kubernetes
labels that's way in which we organize
information altogether so from your
user-defined labels to anything else so
you can keep track of where your
application is no matter where it's
running and in the you know many
different possible kubernetes components
that may be be scheduled so we're now at
the end of the talk thank you very much
for joining we may have time for a
couple of questions
[Music]